malerische landschaften schroffe
bergwelten grüne täler und kleine
bauerndörfer das alles bietet die neue
wanderroute über die alpen
start ist in süddeutschland erst mal
geht es noch ganz gemütlich in gmund am
tegernsee los die teilnehmer der
wandergruppe haben eines gemeinsam
keiner ist geübte bergsteiger alle sind
gespannt ob die eigenen fähigkeiten für
die siebentägige tour ausreichen recht
alpin hohen gipfeln vorbeikommt aber
dass der weg doch recht angenehm so
gemütlich zugehen ist auf der strecke
auf ein paar schöne gasthäuser liegen
und daher
einfach ein paar schöne eindrücke schöne
strecken zum laufen
dann las ich nicht mal überraschen
die tour führt auf leichten bis
mittelschweren wegen zum alpenhauptkamm
genau die gesamte strecke ist 110
kilometer lang
der österreicher georg plata hat sich
die rother ausgedacht
der besondere reiz einer
alpenüberquerung ist dass man sozusagen
von zu hause starten kann
in deutschland und dann über
verschiedene regionen bis in den süden
hin und bekommt dabei unterschiedliche
kulturen zu erleben unterschiedliche
landschaften zu sehen
ein vorteil dieser tour das schwere
gepäck wird mit dem auto hinterher
gebracht
drei tage wandert die gruppe durch
süddeutschland richtung österreich
hinter der grenze wird es langsam
anstrengender es geht hinauf auf 1800
meter
dabei erfahren die wanderer auch einiges
über die bergregion
der kredit ist hartes gestein dass das
alles oberirdisch abfließt und deswegen
sind hier über all diese kleinen bäche
auch voll mit wasser
übrigens bestes trinkwasser kann man
überall die wasserflasche auffüllen
seit jahrtausenden wandern menschen über
die alpen im siebzehnten jahrhundert
wurde die alpenüberquerung zur
bildungsreise für adlige die bekannteste
alpenüberquerung der geschichte aber ist
die des katarischen heerführer sunnyvale
218 vor christus
er zog mit elefanten über die berge
vom mythos alpenüberquerung zum
freizeitspaß
heute wandern auch immer mehr junge
leute jeder der mal eine wanderung
unternommen hat und dann am abend müde
ins bett fällt hungrig ins bett fällt
dann sieht da habe ich mir wirklich
etwas gutes getan
eine sportart eigentlich die nicht
besonders extrem ist gelenkschonend und
trotzdem verbrennt man viele kalorien
am sechsten tag kommt der höhepunkt der
alpenüberquerung der aufstieg zum
hauptgang auf 2.246 meter kühlen 5 grad
celsius passieren die wanderer den
talübergang am feature york und
erreichen zum ersten mal italien
wahnsinnig schön es ist ein gewaltiger
eindrücke des panorama das erschlägt an
fast der letzte streckenabschnitt führt
hinunter ins tal
die gruppe wandert durch blühende
sommerwiesen vorbei an urigen
bauernhöfen bis sie am ende der tour in
sterzing ankommt sterzing auch
italienisch wie bitte
ich bin noch liste stadt des landes
zeit für ein fazit viele regionen kennen
gelernt die natur ist abwechslungsreich
hat mir alles besonders hat mir diese
unglaubliche vielfalt gefallen
zum einen der leidenschaft dass man ja
angefangen hat in diesen lieblichen
mittelgebirgs gelände am tegernsee und
dann hoch gestiegen ist bis in alpine
welten am feature york zwar braucht kein
sportler sein dass man es machen kann
und werde auf jeden fall normal alpen
überzeugung machen im herbst zur
belohnung nach sieben tagen in
wanderschuhen kommt in sterzing etwas
deftiges auf den tisch
knödel speisen sind eine delikatesse in
dieser region dazu ein südtiroler wein
so ist der muskelkater an den wagen ganz
schnell vergessen